- I'm about to use my medical experience
to tell you five of the healthiest items
you can get in Taco Bell
and the one that's the most unhealthy.
But I need some help for this video,
so please welcome Andrew from
"Babish Culinary Universe".
- Oh, hey, what's up man?
- We're gonna be talking Taco Bell,
and really where I'm making this decision
from is four factors.
One, sodium levels.
Two, fiber.
Three, protein.
And calories.
And it's really all about
trying to keep it reasonable,
rather than super healthier
or super unhealthy.
Does that make sense?
- Absolutely.
Whole ingredients, fewer of
them, less preservatives.
It's good, it's gooder for you.
- And you're gonna be taste testing.
Are you excited?
- Very. I love Taco Bell. (chuckles)
- Okay, well let's get started.
Bee whoop.
- Bee whoop.
(both laughing)
(narrator speaking foreign language)
- You see a Taco Bell,
what's the first food you go for?
- Double decker taco,
the one with the cheese.
- You go for a soft shell taco.
But the hack that I wanna give people
is that there's a specific way
to order a soft shell
taco that is healthy.
It's called Al Fresco,
where they basically insert vegetables
to replace some of the
saturated fatty components
of the food, like the sour
cream, like the cheese.
- So by vegetables you mean a little bit
of lettuce and tomatoes?
- Well I've heard tomatoes are fruits,
but only 'cause Dan told me that earlier.
- Oh, I just got caught
on camera saying it.
I'll never live that down.
- The idea here is it's calorically dense.
It's a 150 calories in a little package,
which is nice.
You have some protein content
'cause of the chicken,
and because you're going Al Fresco style,
you only have four grams of fat
with one gram being saturated fat.
- What I am gonna say is that taco.
Eugh. (laughs)
- I was gonna say this
taco doesn't feel nice.
It's like an aged taco.
- It's got some rings on it, like a good,
like a good piece of oak, you know?
It's been compressed.
It's kind of all mushed in there.
The tortilla's very soft,
which I really don't like.
The chicken is clearly marinated.
I mean look at the marination.
- And they were not supposed
to put sour cream in the Al Fresco style,
so they've let us down already.
- [Andrew] Oh Jesus.
- But that's okay.
- Yeah, that's fine. I'll eat it.
- 'Cause that's what's
probably gonna happen
when you go and you- (chuckles)
- They're not gonna get
you what you ordered.
This looks like real chicken.
It's not like a chicken
patty product or anything.
I see real grain and musculature.
The lettuce is on top,
which is, that's a taco.
- Okay.
(Andrew laughing)
That is a taco.
- The cheese,
the cheese is very finely shredded,
but you can see it's still-
- [Mike] But it's hid all in one place.
- Yeah, it's all in one place,
and you see it's still kind of broken up,
and that's probably
because they're putting
anticoagulants and
anticaking agents on it,
which just leads to a bad experience.
Plus you're getting extra starch in there
that you don't need.
- You don't need that.
- Mm.
(upbeat music)
- A lot of sour cream in one bite.
A lot of sour cream.
- A lot of unmelted cheese.
- We're having different experiences
eating the same food right now.
- I can feel the separate
shreds of cheese in my mouth.
I'm gonna try the chicken
and see what we're working with here.
We got some grill marks on it.
That's pretty cool.
- You think that's legitimate?
- No, definitely painted on there
by a robot that hates humans.
- The great part about their website is
that they give a great
nutrition fact section
for each food.
This is a calorically appropriate food
if you're trying to be low calorie.
There's some protein in there.
What ingredient would you add to this
to give it a little...
Mmm.
A pepper?
- Hot sauce, definitely. (chuckles)
- Yeah, give it a little kick.
- And I don't know how you feel about that
'cause of the sodium,
but hot sauce is just the meal saver.
Everything that we get from here,
you load it up with that hot sauce-
- Yeah.
- And it tastes better.
- And there's way to improve the spiciness
without adding salt.
There's ones with zero calories.
There's one with zero sodium,
with vinegar as the main component.
So there's ways to do it.
Oh, hold on a second.
This is a real moment.
I have a chicken bone in my chicken.
- No.
No.
That's never happened before
in the history of Taco Bell.
It's your first time trying it.
- Dude, this is my first time,
and this is a sharp bone.
- Their chickens don't even have bones.
- Hold on a second, can we sue?
Food number two,
bean burrito.
- Ooh.
- Why do we go bean?
Fiber, protein, generally
speaking low fat.
- Gas.
- Well, what happens is part
of the fiber your body can't
digest, so it goes through,
but then the bacteria that
naturally live in your gut,
they digest it, and what do they do?
- [Andrew] Fart.
- And then you fart.
- It's not-
- It's not even your fart.
- That makes me feel a whole lot better.
- Yeah.
So you can blame it.
Yeah, you can blame it on the bacteria.
- I'm gonna do that next time at a party.
- So we have the bean burrito,
but this time, instead
of the red bean sauce,
which packs on the sodium
'cause a traditional bean
burrito has 1,040 milligrams
of sodium, which is half your day's sodium
for an average person
in an average situation
for an average nutrition.
- I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that seems like too much salt.
- But you can lower it
by removing the red bean sauce,
and just putting tomatoes
in, like we requested.
Let's see if they listened.
- [Andrew] I see tomatoes.
- [Mike] Okay, I see tomatoes.
But I feel like there's
still red bean sauce on here.
Is that not red bean sauce?
- [Andrew] It's a hot sauce.
- Oh.
- Can I...
- Yeah.
- That's hot sauce.
- Hot sauce, okay.
- Wait, did we get hot sauce on these?
- [Crew] Not intentionally.
- That's insane.
- You gotta love it.
But there are some onions.
There are some tomatoes.
There are some beans,
which are ingredients that
I would say are healthy.
(relaxing music)
This is very beany.
- That's all bean.
- It's all bean.
I mean-
- It's a bean burrito.
- There are worst foods than beans.
- I'll tear this apart from
a culinary perspective,
if you want.
- Please.
- [Andrew] Garbage.
- Okay.
What, why. Elaborate on the garbage.
- There's very little flavor.
The texture is only soft and squishy.
- Yes.
- The beans are really all there is.
- And I know some people
like bean burritos.
This might be a bias for me,
but that's just not the
core component that I want.
I need some rigidity here, okay?
Otherwise we just have a
big old flaccid, you know,
whatever this is.
- Nobody wants a flaccid bean burrito.
- And look what happens.
So now we're onto the Power Bowl.
- [Mike] The Veggie Power Bowl.
- Funkalicious.
(upbeat music)
- Do they only have three
vegetables at Taco Bell?
I just see beans, tomatoes and rice.
- [Mike] Yeah, probably.
- [Andrew] That sucks.
- And I still don't think
tomato's a vegetable,
no matter how hard we try today.
- I keep forgetting that.
- There's also some avocado
ranch sauce on here.
This little amount of
sauce has soybean oil,
cultured buttermilk, water,
avocado, cage-free egg yolk,
vinegar, white wine
vinegar, 2% or less of...
(Mike speaking at fast speed)
And milk and eggs that
are certified vegetarian.
- What is all that (censored) for?
I know it is preservatives
and anticoagulants,
but like, did they taste it,
and they were like you know what,
it doesn't have enough (censored).
- A lot of ingredients
that we can't pronounce are
actually safe ingredients
that have been tested,
but my question is why?
This is a densely caloric rich food.
400 calories.
You got fiber in there.
- [Andrew] Wait, this is guacamole.
- [Mike] Yeah, we're missing guacamole.
- We didn't get any guacamole.
- Yeah, no guacamole.
- That's a vegetable.
That's a good vegetable, right?
That's, it's fatty.
- Yeah, it's good fat,
unsaturated fat.
- All right, I'm gonna start
with each individual component,
then we're gonna mix it
up into a big monstrosity.
- I don't have any skills,
so I'm just gonna eat it.
- Oh God.
Oh my God.
- That ranch sauce is just water.
- This rice tastes like chlorine.
(Mike laughing)
I'm not joking.
There is an astringent quality. (chuckles)
- I would venture to say musky.
I mean I like that these
are black beans though.
Black beans have virtually no fat.
- Oh, really?
And they're very good for you.
- Protein.
- Iron.
- Fiber.
Dare I say, the healthiest item
in Taco Bell is right here in front of us.
- [Andrew] What is it?
- It's one ingredient made
up of seven ingredients.
(both laughing)
It has protein. It has fiber.
It's black beans.
- [Andrew] Oh, it's black beans.
- 50 calories.
Three grams of protein,
three grams of fiber.
- Oh, it looks delicious.
- And you know who's going to love this?
- Me?
- The bacteria inside your gut.
- Oh, my bacteria.
What's in the black beans?
- [Mike] It's normal (censored). Yeah.
- [Andrew] Except for natural flavor.
What the hell is that?
- I ate all of it.
- Oh my God, you did.
- 50 calories. It's the
healthiest thing I could eat.
Might as well maximize the gains.
- What do you think, folks?
Do you wanna look like this or
do you wanna look like this?
(Mike laughing)
Eat your beans.
- [Mike] The Black Bean
Crunchwrap Supreme.
- Bless you, Taco Bell.
- This is the hottest ticket at Taco Bell.
- This is popular, but we
have to make it Al Fresco.
- Of course.
- We have to replace the sour
cream with diced tomatoes.
- I'm not trying to die.
So we have ourselves a crunchwrap supreme.
- I'm gonna treat this
like a patient encounter.
Hello.
(cricket chirping)
My name is Dr. Varshavsky.
I'm gonna make an incision vertically.
(cricket chirping)
- Oh, he really is making an incision.
Oh no. It feels so much
more visceral with that.
Beautiful.
Oh, look at that cross section.
- [Mike] Look at that.
- [Andrew] Look at that.
- Honestly, this looks healthy.
- I mean there's a lot.
It's mostly toward the-
- The beans are cut so nicely though.
- Yeah, you cut right through these beans.
- [Mike] I cut right through
the middle of the beans.
- [Andrew] That is surgical.
He did a surgical thing.
- Yeah. This is good. That's a good knife.
Is that your knife?
- Is it? Yeah, it is. Yes, it is.
- Get this. I'm gonna buy this knife.
Where's this available?
- [Andrew] It's available
on Amazon right now.
- [Mike] We're buying
this on Amazon right now.
- How many calories are
we looking at for this?
- [Mike] It's around 500 calories.
- [Andrew] Okay, so for
a small meal, that's not-
- Yeah, it's a meal. Yeah.
If you're having three meals a day,
that's 1600 calories a day.
That's very reasonable.
- Get three of these
a day. You'll be fine.
- Yeah, well.
- I'm kidding, sorry. (laughs)
- Honestly, it's not bad though.
- The fried tortilla brings
a lot of flavor, like,
- Yeah.
- which it adds oil.
It adds cooked corn, which is
a very flavorful ingredient.
- This isn't what I would
call a healthy food.
- Yeah.
- I would call it
the healthier option.
- Yes.
- The least healthy thing in Taco Bell.
High in saturated fat, high in calories,
high in sodium, high
in carbs, low in fiber,
The Breakfast Crunchwrap Sausage Supreme.
- [Andrew] Oh, God.
- Yeah, I'll take a
breakfast crunch thing.
- [Andrew] It's so markedly thicker
and different than the beans.
- [Mike] And there's no beans in this one.
- [Andrew] There's no beans.
- So you're not getting your fibers.
- So I'm actually gonna like it.
(Mike laughing)
- [Mike] You get a hash brown.
You get sausage.
You get egg.
You get cheese.
You get dressing.
There's a lot happening on
this little piece of food.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- My cholesterol's high.
There's so much saturated fat.
What is it?
47 grams of total fat in
this tiny little thing.
- [Andrew] Whoa. That's insane.
- That's a bomb.
- [Sam] Under what circumstances
should people eat this?
- You're lost in the desert.
(crew laughing)
- Well, that was a lot.
- It was a lot.
- This tastes like the whole thing
went through the deep fryer just for fun.
- That's factual.
- What I really like
to do is make not only
like a better, you know,
whole food version,
but also make it a little bit healthier.
- Okay.
- And it still has lots
of flavor and you make it yourself.
You meal prep it and freeze it.
- We can switch roll.
- We switch roles.
- Okay, so I'll taste test.
You make it healthy.
- I was hoping you'd cook.
- I don't know how to do that.
- Ah. Well, I'd love to do
that for you on my channel.
I'm gonna do a basics episode
and I'd love for you
to swing by and try it.
- Let's do it.
Click here to check out that episode.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)